so Sam bakeman fried as we just told you
at some length was the headliner Sam
bankman Fred everybody applause applause
at the New York Times deal book Summit a
few hours ago was a top business leader
can't overstate how weird it was at one
point Andrew Sorkin from The New York
Times who promoted Sam bankman freed on
television at length in previous months
and years asked how customers could
learn to be safe online as if Sam bacon
free just didn't rip off his own
customers
but the main takeaway from the whole
thing is that Sam bankman freed isn't
stupid he knows he's bulletproof he
knows the Democratic Party in the SEC
and his friend Gary Gensler won't touch
him
so watch Sam bankman freed explain that
actually he's not very worried about
criminal charges
How concerned are you about criminal
liability at this point
so I don't think that I mean obviously I
don't personally think that I have uh
you know
but
I I think the real answer is that's not
it sounds weird to say but but I think
the real answer is that's not what I'm
focusing on I mean look I I've had a bad
month
um this is not getting fun for me but
that's not what matters here
I've had a bad month it's all about me
and my personal Journey but being held
accountable by Regulators the justice
department the U.S Congress these are my
friends I paid for them boy if there's
ever been a clear window into the deep
corruption we really need to get rid of
if we're going to return to
representative democracy it's that right
there so saying bank and feed seems so
confident that he's Untouchable that he
admitted in public to co-mingling funds
between FTX his crypto exchange and a
separate company he control that's the
kind of thing that Regulators would
normally care about but in this case for
some reason didn't watch
FTX didn't have bank accounts it didn't
have any bank accounts globally
we were trying to get them
um
it took us a while took us a few years
um
and
you know there are customers who wanted
to wire money to FTX
and so I think in the meantime
um some of them were wiring money to
Alameda research to get credited on FTS
and uh I think that was a substantial
sum uh and I think that the ftx's
internal accounting did correctly
effectively try to debit Alameda
for those funds
you know the New York Times is not a TV
show it's a newspaper and when they want
to find out about somebody we can speak
from first-hand experience they put a
whole bunch of reporters on the story
for months and they may interview the
person they're writing about they also
interview a lot of other people and they
create a full account of what they
claimed happened they're not doing that
with this guy they're bringing him on to
allow him to whitewash what he did
huh
but aware that he may have had a bad
week as he just said bankman free tried
to do some damage control watch this
was there commingling of funds that's
what it appears like it appears like
there's a genuine co-mingling of the
funds that are of FTX customers that
were not supposed to be commingled with
your separate firm
I ain't knowing leeco mingle fonts I
wasn't trying to co-mingle funds
is the founder and executive chairman of
strive asset management and deeply
familiar with the world of Finance he
joins us tonight Vivek thanks so much
for coming on so what was lacking I I
felt in all of this was the moral
outrage you would associate with someone
who apparently stole billions from like
retirement funds but the New York Times
treated him like yeah you know maybe he
got a little you know you did some bad
things or whatever but there's no like
it's not like he's Donald Trump or
something right like what is that
you know the thing that was striking
about this Tucker is it actually
reminded me of a lot of what we saw in
the aftermath of the 2008 financial
crisis where you had firms that again
positioned themselves like they wanted
to be the good guys the Goldman Sachs is
the Morgan stanleys and in fact the
difference back then was that they even
got bailed out by the government
directly at the public Fisk now here in
the case of SBF this is a guy who wore
t-shirt and shorts and the thing that
was fascinating for me for watching that
Tucker today wasn't so much SBF he's
really good at deflection using a lot of
technocratic language to deflect
accountability the thing that was
actually interesting was looking at the
people in the audience nervously
laughing distancing themselves from him
and to me when I was thinking about what
happened in 2008 Tucker I think the
interesting part of this is the people
in that audience the other Financial
Elites who now are trying to distance
themselves from the guy who wore t-shirt
and shorts actually are not all that
different from him in kind they may be
different in degree but not in kind and
I think that's the thing that people
actually struggle with with this SBF
story if they're an elite Finance when
they look themselves in the mirror and
look at the kinds of things that
happened in 2008 you know what it's an
uncomfortable parallel and an
uncomfortable similarity and in a
certain sense he's just one of them and
they're just one of him that was one of
my takeaways from actually watching
today that's that's that's the that's
the deepest truth of this whole thing
that's exactly right fake thank you for
your insightful analysis of that
speaking from Noah thank you good to see
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight